接下来讲。
所有人都一直盯着这里啊。
就觉一个视角呃人物啊、视角啊事情。其实心里我这么一说啊，你们心里都有数了，都不是难处理。
但是这个线性叙事啊。
有些人是在琢磨的。
说有些片子可不是现行虚事。
有没有非线性叙事的片子？
你们能想到的。
那个。
就算它是算它是非线性趋势。
疯狂的石头。
花里胡哨的吧。
叮咣叮咣这一下那一下非线性吧，挺隧道的，反正是。
对吧。
类似于疯狂的石头的这种叙事方式的。
还有一个电影叫情侣门。
韩国的一个电影。
挺好看的，你们可以去下载看一下韩国电影叫情侣门。
这疯狂的石头疯狂石头大家比较熟悉，我们就来讲一讲疯狂的石头。
讲一讲所谓的这个。
非线性虚食。
他是不是复杂趋势？我先。
再次声明我这节课我的立场啊。
有没有复杂叙事？
空啊很空。
我跟你说，你们。
我先讲吧，我给你们讲完嘿嘿。
你们在排聊。
擦出一块地儿。
我们来讲讲所谓的。
所谓的非线性叙事啊。
所谓的非。
所谓的非线性。
有些同学还会说啊，那倒叙算不算非线性？倒叙是算线性，倒叙，我们把它归在线性里。我不管你看到哪本书里，它怎么归，你听我的课，我就告诉你把它归在线性里面，你把它们中间一段拿到最前面说一下，或者你把结尾拿到最前面说一下。
不叫什么非线性，那还是你是按照线性写的。我跟你讲，最后你看到那样片子呈现出来呃，把结尾拿出来，在前面比划了一下，增强一下悬念，或者是增强一下观众期待，那都不一定是编剧干的，你懂我意思吧？那有可能是导演的主意或者是剪辑师干的，因为有可能是制制片人干涉。
说哎呀往前提一段吧，这个开头太散太惨了，对吧？太差了，那就是线性叙事，你就按照线性叙事写。
那么把后面一场戏提到前面啊，你就不是线性了啊。
别吹这种牛逼啊。
倒叙那些这的咱就不讨论。
我就说这个我们就说这个石头好吧，疯狂石头宁浩导演的。
这个这个成名制作，开山之作非常好非常好，从观赏的角度非常好。
大家不要去跟我说别的。
你爱不爱看好不好看，好看，那就是好，这电影就是好，你说他。
是怎么个叙事？我们还从我们的那个分法啊，简单叙事。我们说人物。
视角吗？
事情。
对吧。
非线性我们给他了。
我们说简单故事里面是一个人物，一个视角，一个事情嘛，我们还是从这三个角度来来理解这个事儿啊，疯狂的十道件。
我们说人物有多少？
人物多不多？
郭涛他们的是一伙，这个毫无疑问。
对吧。
我们就不不说他叫什么了啊，因为记不清楚了。
我没有提前备课，没有提前看片子，我就凭记忆跟大家说，不会说错的，大家放心，我不会草率的。
郭涛他们一伙，这毫无疑问。
黄渤那也算一会儿吧，那这吧就有一伙儿很主要的角色。在但是大哥是道哥，咱就说道哥吧，好吧。
哥那一伙。
咱还是得尊这个这个尊重大道哥是大哥呀，你在写黄渤那会，你你让道哥颜面河寸，是不是？咱这出来混的这大哥，就是大哥来道哥这一伙是吧？
我顶了肥也算一会吧，我顶了一个肥呀。
港那个香港香香港那个港位。
是吧。
稿费算一会吧。
然后徐峥跟那个四川那个娃子张迅徐峥张迅算一伙儿吧。
徐峥派迅读而来也是极度捣乱嘛。
对吧无人驾驶，高考技啊，对吧？那个那个那个迅哥。
我们就叫他迅哥吧，迅哥算一伙吧。
对吧。
然后还有一个一个那个重要力量。
那个。
搞摄影的那个。
富二代。
这个层死的母体，那个那个家伙琉璃厂那个那个厂厂长儿子那个二代，对吧？我们叫他二代。
我们说来。
这五谷势力。
我们为什么说这个二代明显不是主角？
但我们为什么使他无股实力？因为他从这5个角度都。
都曾经叙事。
都曾经蓄世了。
我们说这是他的5个虚实角度，我们这么去理解。
确实挺乱的。
但我告诉你啊。
他怎么写的？
还怎么写？
说人物啊。
视角人物。
主角人物。
郭涛才是贯穿始终的。
郭涛的目标保护那个石头。
换回自己的工资。
我们来看啊，我们不去看这些花里胡哨的玩意儿，我们不去看这些花里胡哨的。
的其他角色我们就来理郭涛的线，我给你从头到尾捋一遍。
郭涛开场。
对不对？开场就是郭涛，开场画面就是人家，他在干嘛？
他的尿尿。
他尿不出尿。
这是什么？
你告诉我这是什么？
这是个缺陷。
而且很可怜。
作为三十来岁的年纪。
首先开场做的他可怜，我告来回忆一下上节课这里为什么要做可怜？
增强共情。
想让观众站在他的角度。
然后第二场戏就是。
缺钱。
没有工资。
工资老板欠他工资。
缺钱。
对吧，然后后来接下来发生了什么事儿？
厂里出现了一块。
老坑翡翠呀，找到一块老坑翡翠，然后他他得到一个什么任务啊？
保护这个老坑翡翠。
对不对？而且保护这个老坑翡翠。
的条件是什么？只要保护这个老头翡碎，工资发给他。
解决他要钱的问题，他的欲望是要钱钱很要钱很原始，没问题。他的欲望是要钱，他的动作呢？
保护石头。
保护石头，保护好了就可以给我钱，他动作是保护石头。
然后他的结局是什么？
石头没保护好，但是得到钱了。石头最后他手里那个其实是真的石头。
记得吗？
最后石头落在他手里了，当然他不知道。
误打误撞。但是我们说。
主角的结果是什么来着？
绕过动作。
直现于我，他的动作是保护石头，他最后没有保护好石头。
但是实现了欲望，他不缺钱了。
你告诉我，郭涛不是主角，是什么？
它是100%的正儿八经的。
主角。
他是正儿八经的主角，你从这个角度理解，他其实是一个单一人物的。
对。
你不要被黄渤精湛的演技给迷惑了，就认为。
这个片子是有多么花哨。
首先从人物这个角度啊。
我们。
我们说主角毋庸置疑是郭逃。
从头到尾是他没有改变过。
做的一切。
就创作者做的一切。
出店一切这个这个这个安排都明确的告诉你，郭涛是这个戏的主角。
这四个人呢？
分别是干嘛的？
我讲这四个人是同样的。
全都是他保护石头的阻力。
全都是反派。
其实全都是反派。
但是这个戏做了一件什么事儿啊，你记得他叙事非常花哨。
对不对？
我们光记得他叙事非常花哨了。
丁光这一下那一下，他是怎么做到的？我现在告诉你，这些人明明是反派。
他们其实不应该出场那么早的。
比如说道哥他们这一伙，他带着黄渤，还有另外一个小弟，他们要偷这个石头，对吧？
他们不应该出场那么早的，以郭涛为视角，郭涛是主角的话，那么就等到。
比如说他们是。
假设这你看这四个都是来偷石头的。
来偷或者来抢的。
假设道哥和黄渤他们是第三波。
下手的那就到第三波的时候讲他们呀。
他们只不过是涛哥前进路上四朵波澜，其中的一朵而已都不一定是最大的那一朵。
对吧。
那他是怎么叙事的？
回忆一下。
我告诉你。
我们就先说道哥他们这一伙儿。
道哥在他们这会是怎么出场？
他们为什么会出场？
因为。
他们偷了港哥的设备。
发现这个港哥。
的目标是翡翠。
等于是他跟他。
先发生了。
连接。
发生连接以后。
偷了他东西之后，知道了那块石头，我们以石头我们还是。
这个戏为什么叫疯狂的石头？
因为石头是中心。
对吧石头石东西，然后。
道哥偷了岗位的东西。
跟石头。
发生了连接。
首先。
这是一个。
连接。
然后道哥。
他们确定了这个目标之后。
确定这个目标之后。
入住了。
砸烂石头。
那个场地旁边的小旅馆。
恰好跟戈涛跟郭涛住隔壁。
而且因为公共厕所。
上公共厕所还。
打了个照面。
等于是。
强迫道哥提前出场。
就他跟涛哥。
提前见面跟港费提前见面，对吧？
稿费是哪来的？
是迅哥徐峥，他们是迅哥请来的。
他俩之间。
是他他俩之间又有联系，他雇佣他俩的。
是吧。
明白这个意思吧？他雇佣他来。
他的东西被他偷了。
然后他也盯了这个石头，然后跟郭涛住国住隔壁。
然后迅哥呢。
迅哥为什么那么早出场？
就前面有有他什么事儿呢？
他的车。
又被郭涛给撞了。
他的车呀，他BMW别磨我。
被郭涛的那个一个金杯给撞了，然后让郭郭涛赔钱。
记得吗？这件事情也是石头以外的。
与石头无关的。
他们跟郭涛之间。
发生了汽水儿。
上厕所，还有可乐的事件也是石头以外的。
明白这个意思吧？
他跟他的连接。
是偷他的箱子，因为它的箱子看起来很有值钱，也是石头以外的，明白这个意思吧？
二代。
二代跟这个石头有什么关系？
这是他爹的场。
等于他跟郭涛本来就认识他们一个厂的，他是二代。
他为什么又出厂那么早呢？
有他什么事啊。
他把道哥的女朋友给睡了。
记不记得？
他把道哥的女朋友给睡了，记得吗？
那个那个。
我爱你亲爱的姑娘，那首歌想起来的时候，他不是盯上人家的女朋友了吗？
你现在明白这个戏当时你看的是什么了吗？
眼花缭乱的巧合。
我其实不推荐巧合的。
巧合这个东西啊。
你用好了。
就是疯狂的石候。
让你眼花缭乱，目无暇接。
用不好。
就迅速的失失去了。
观众。
因为他会觉得也太巧了。
你为了给我讲个精彩的故事。
你说你为了给我讲一个精彩的故事，说我今天出去遛弯，碰上一个人，对吧？然后呢，他呢是英国的威廉王子。
挺巧的，为了王子在双井地区让你碰上。
然后聊了聊呢，你又听说他其实。
不是亲儿子，他还有一层绅士，他。
他情爹是其实是迈克尔乔丹。
是吧你光整这一套是花掉了，但是迅速的。
这个故事你讲给朋友听的时候，迅速的别朋友就跟他别说了，别吹了，对吧？就不信你了。这个故事就是有这个风险。
就是有这个风险，他玩了大量的巧合。
让你。
看起来每个人的戏份都极足。你看啊想偷石头的这四股恶势力，互相之间千丝万缕的连接，其实是冒着极大的失去。
信任的风险的。
凭什么他就正好睡了他的女朋友？
对吧。
凭什么他的车就被他给撞了？
对吧凭什么他的东西就恰好被他的给偷了。
就全部纠葛在一块了，而且他们都跟郭涛发生联系。
所以他是用这种。
用这些连接，等于强迫这些人提前出场，在非他们该出场的地方就提前出场了。因为交代这种关系，所以造成叙事，一会儿这个视角，一会那个视角，一会儿这儿一会儿那儿。
然后你看的很过瘾，为什么呢？是因为在这种叙事的方式下。
他们有太多的巧合和秘密，把观众顶在了一个视角，叫上帝视角。
你掌控全局，你什么都看到了，你什么都明白，然后你觉得你自己很拽。
很开心，你享受的那。
那种做上帝的感觉，无所不知的感觉。
然后在这种情况下。
这个故事。
做的很成功。
他让每个角色。
出来的都没有违和感。
让你觉得都很合理。
然后呢呃压住了主角的光芒，牺牲了主角的共情。
把共情放在哪了呢？共情放在上帝了，放在上帝视角了，你在看着这一群人闹，你没有你看这个片子的时候，你没有替郭涛担心过，你没有担心说，哎呀涛哥的这个石头要是被偷了。涛哥这个保安的工作可能要丢了。哎呀，那他媳妇儿，他那个在公交车上卖票的媳妇儿。
该多难过呀，你没有产生这个共情。
因为导演刻意的把这个共情给撇掉了，他也放弃了，他不要了。
对吧。
你也没有真正的站在道哥那儿，希望道哥拿到那个石头，跟他那个给他戴绿帽子的女朋友呃重归于好。没有。
你也没有。
你就更不可能站在呃迅迅哥那里或者是稿费那里，或者是二代那里。
那更不可能你在你自始至终站在上帝视角，他就是用这种叙事方式把你拱到上帝视角了。因为信息量太大，互相之间全部全都不知情，只有你一个人知情，只有观众知情，他等于用五个方向看起来是5个五五线叙事啊，他营造了一个假五线叙事的。
一个局面。其实从剧本来说，就是郭涛的。
八要素。
核时序列。
只不过是郭涛在保护这个石头中遇到的四个阻力。
做大做强，不光是做大做强，做变异。
做他妈扩散了，你懂我意思吧？肿起来的。
然后呢，肿起来之后，那得有细分给撑呀，然后就做疯狂的做巧合。
而且是有点冒险的。
做了一些巧合，把他们。
查在一块儿，把这四五个势力硬查在一块儿。
非常的冒险。
但是人家。
靠着镜头靠着表演。
靠着叙事的流畅程度。
叮咣叮咣给你讲完了。
让你觉得啊过瘾，看完了。
对吧甚至再看第二遍哇过瘾，再看第三遍哇过瘾。
连看好几遍都没有看出来。
他是怎么玩的？
其实你说。
是不是现性趋势？
非用废物。
空啊。
你非说它是多线。
那他就是多谢。
你理解它是多谢，你你愿意理解为多谢，那么他就是喽。
你说他不是。
他就是郭涛的单线蓄势，只不过是郭涛的四个对手肿起来了，扩散了。
也O了。
我是比较倾向于。
你用线性故事去理解。
就是你你要化简化繁为节。
把故事。
往简单里理解，因为你是从简单里写出来的呀，明白这个意思吧？
我们是在学写剧本，我们是上编剧课，我给你把。
疯狂的石头，这个剧本吹的天花乱坠，告诉你此物只应天上有。
有什么用呢？你也学不会。
我告诉你，他原本也是一个。
简单叙事也是一个单一人物，单一视角。
单一事情现境趋世。
然后他慢慢的长成了这个样子。
你了解它生长的这个过程，以及他他这个强迫它生长，他打了哪些激素。而同时我也告诉你打这些激素有哪些副作用，你要注意一下。
我没说不能打。
有时候确实很过瘾的。
是利伟哥他确实待劲了。
对吧你看他确实待定了。
他把这四个反派做大做强了之后，确实带劲了。
而且做大做强之后，你就有一种替他们着想的感觉。
你明白这个意思吧？我们有一度挺替黄渤那个角色着想了。
挺替道哥不值了。
就是你把它做大做强了，它自然就会吸引观众的一部分爱。
然后呢，你让观众处处留情，你这个戏就是让观众处处留情，最后观众就就被顶到了。
这个这个这个我说的这个上帝视角嘛。
明白这个意思吧？
咱们今天就是讲这个疯狂的石头。
作为所谓的复杂叙事最重要的案例。
让大家理解一下。
我说的非有非无啊。
空了。
很空啊。
那这节课就在这么空空中就结束吧。好吧，我希望大家早日顿悟。
下课。